hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his article what is philosophy as a
way of life john
sellers considers the possible ways of
understanding
that movement a very important
contemporary movement in philosophy and
one that goes back
into philosophy's very beginnings in the
west
and the the two main we could call them
dominant ways of understanding and doing
philosophy
in the west certainly in the
anglo-american
sphere of english-speaking countries
analytic philosophy
and continental philosophy
and there's a number of different ways
in which we can
frame this so one of the ways is that
philosophy as a way of life is doing
something
that doesn't neatly fit into either of
these it's not on either side of the
divide
it's a third way it's an alternative a
different way of framing it would be
that there's more connections between
philosophy as a way of life with
continental
philosophy than there is with analytic
philosophy
so before we go on too much further
we should say a little bit about
analytic and continental philosophy
these are kind of fuzzy categories
they are largely associated with
linguistic
and cultural spheres it's not to say
that that everything
in america and britain is analytic
philosophy clearly not the case because
there's continental philosophy there
as well and there was you know classical
american philosophy there's a lot of
history of philosophy that gets ignored
by
by anglo-american analytic philosophy
but that is that has become sort of the
predominant way
of doing philosophy from you know the
let's say the 50s onward in
america great britain australia
canada all sorts of other places as well
and it's had some influence on
uh you know european philosophy there
are some people who are very interested
in in
analytic philosophy particularly in
scandinavia and germany and
in other places as well then we have
continental philosophy
this is a really fuzzy category and what
we
typically call continental philosophy or
teaches continental philosophy
in say america is just a
window on the the much you know vaster
swath
of european philosophy prime example is
the person i wrote my dissertation on
maurice blondel
um you know not very much taught about
in
in continental philosophy circles as a
matter of fact many continentalists are
very surprised to find out that he
already did things that say bergstone is
credited with or
dairy does credited with or you know
people like that
and that's in part because they don't
know the literature in part because
there's this narrow
window so continental philosophy is
often
posed as sort of like well whatever
analytic philosophy isn't and all that
weird stuff coming from france germany
maybe italy and spain and places like
that so
i know that that is you know a thumbnail
sketch
and and don't rely on that as like the
definitive word
about these but i think that's that's
useful enough for this
so you know one way of understanding
philosophy as a way of life
is that it would be connected with and
perhaps even encompass
some continental philosophy and you know
sellers brings up some really
interesting contrast here he says
that between continental existentialism
and
oxford linguistic philosophy in the 50s
or 60s
or engaged marxism and quinian
naturalism a little bit later on
he says if we if we look at those it
seems not unreasonable that continental
philosophers are the heirs of socrates
that is the humanistic way of doing
philosophy well analytic philosophies
are heirs to
aristotle more you know scientific
knowledge for its own sake
kind of orientation towards philosophy
and i think that
you know it does make sense to talk
about the existentialists fitting in
there or
engaged marxists fitting in there as
well
and that word engaged is very important
because it's quite possible to be kind
of an ivory tower
or as we used to joke about them neiman
marx is named after of course the
very famous department store neiman
marcus
these people that don't have any real
practice
but even if we're thinking about that
it's not as if
what was going on on the continent or
particularly in france
was all philosophy as a way of life as
opposed to the british who were just you
know chopping logic and looking at
language
and you know disengaged from philosophy
and society
because you know another major thing
that was going on at the time that
existentialism and
marxism were really like big parts of
the philosophical scene was
structuralism
and structuralism is you know not
philosophy is the way i like very
clearly not
i mean some post-structuralist authors
like roland bartz
maybe yes uh if you think that you know
reading and literature
is a way of doing philosophy as a way of
life but most of the hardcore
structuralists
very few of whom are read at this
present time are well known
um definitely not that and and you know
foucault talks about what it was like
when he was coming up
where existentialism marxism and
structuralism were like the
big things that were going on you know
we could also say is hermeneutics which
is big in germany
um a philosophy is a way of life you
know
it's it's a little bit dubious now
sellers does bring up
nietzsche nietzsche is is clearly
somebody
who belongs within this movement in part
because he he insists so much that
biography
and motivations coming out of that are
essential to philosophy and he's
carrying out this
this critique of philosophers on that
that basis and
you know he brings up phuket as well who
was uh connected with and a contemporary
of
pure ado foucault you know his notion of
technologies of the self would fit in
there
as well and ado himself
as as sellers brings up um pura do
you know talks about uh philosophy as a
way of life including people like
kierkegaard nietzsche bergson merloponti
but he also tells us for adult writing
in paris none of these are continental
philosophers they're just philosophers
and they're all people who are
recuperating what is going on bergson
is one of the people along with maurice
blondell credited with
revitalizing metaphysics within france
in the early part of the 20th century
we could we could count a whole bunch of
other figures in there so there's you
know you could say
some continental philosophy connects up
with
overlaps with philosophy as a way of
life you can't really say
continental philosophy per se does
however
and this is where we get to the
suggestion of perhaps there's a
third way between analytic and
continental philosophy
so he says that it's difficult to make
general
you know we have to put aside the model
of what both both classifications mean
sellers says it's difficult to make
generalizations given that the label
continental philosophy does not really
refer to anything
at all beyond those bits of research
recent western philosophy analytic
philosophers
tend to reject is not how they think
philosophy ought to be done
even so there's many philosophers in the
continental tradition who seem to be
engaged in something
like philosophy as a way of life but
some people have rejected any connection
between the two
and he talks about this guy michael
chase translator of pure
edo who you know obvi you know when
you're a translator
you're doing some pretty thankless work
it's not for the money it's not for the
glory
usually it's because you think that work
deserves to be translated
and there's a whole interesting
narrative here about how
this this chase person studied first
with analytics
and found that the stuff that he was
interested in
uh learning from philosophy they were
totally uninterested and said that's not
really philosophy
and then he's like well i guess i'll go
study with the continentals
maybe it'll be better over there and the
department that he picked over there
it really wasn't any better it's just
you know sort of like the old proverb
you know meet the new boss right say
goodbye to the old boss
it's still somebody you know gatekeeping
channeling what's going to count as as
philosophy
and you know there's there's definitely
something
to this so he here's a great line by
uh sellers like many philosophy students
before and since
who found themselves uninspired by
possible worlds or out-of-control
trolleys
chase decided to you know move on to to
the the only other game
in town and so you know
here's what chase writes i had a taste
of both analytic and continental
philosophy
the two mutually exclusive branches of
the discipline neither had satisfied me
neither seemed to be able to speak to my
thirst for the honest
jargon free discussions of philosophical
issues that genuinely matter to my life
so he wanted a third way he found that
in pure ado
and interestingly he found his way to
pirado the way that
many of us do when it comes to getting
away from analytic and continental stuff
studying greek and latin and going back
to ancient authors and finding out that
the caricatures
of them in analytic philosophy or
continental philosophy
are fake and that the real deal is much
more robust and interesting
and speaks to our contemporary concerns
even though we're separated from them by
two millennia and sometimes more
in some cases and so he says pirando's
conception of philosophy is a way of
life which
doesn't fit neatly into the usual
two-prying division of philosophy into
analytic continental
may provide indications of a third way
as an alternative to both
so this third way idea is worth worth
considering
and sellers says why would it provide a
third way
it doesn't shun the traditional big
philosophical questions
it deals with issues relevant to
people's lives it does not
model itself on the natural sciences
analytic philosophy
and it avoids being ironic or
relativistic
continental philosophy it's a way of
thinking about philosophy today that's
accessible
to non-experts that's a problem for both
analytic and continental philosophy
and connects with the wider history of
philosophy stretching back to antiquity
also a problem for both of them although
continental philosophy there's more
emphasis on reading texts
the average person doing continental
philosophy really doesn't know much
about the stoics or aristotle
or you know boethius or you know
even people they they heavily criticize
like descartes
they know sort of a window into it that
they got from reading heidegger to lose
or whoever right
and so that's you know these are
significant motives for wanting
a third way
so you know seller says that i'm gonna
put whether these images are entirely
fair to the side
i don't doubt for a moment both accounts
accurately present his own experiences
as a student
i've had similar experiences myself no
doubt both traditions are richer than
the instances
chase encountered at university but the
important point is that chase is
proposing
three distinct traditions of philosophy
rather than two
and so rather than a contrast between
scientific and humanistic metaphy
chase's distinction is between two kinds
of equally arid and irrelevant academic
discourse
analytic and continental versus a
venerable ancient
tradition of life-changing wisdom
philosophy is a way of life
now sellers later on will say
yeah i'm not really buying this third
way it's more that philosophy is a way
of life cuts across the analytic
continental divide and that's perhaps a
better way
a more accurate way of thinking about it
granted that in many
local places what passes for analytic or
continental philosophy
may indeed be you know what he's
described here
equally arid and irrelevant academic
discourse
right so the other thing that that
sellers doesn't talk about here but i
think is worth bringing up
in in relation to this section is that
we could think of philosophy as a way of
life as perhaps
intersecting with other things that have
been proposed
as third ways of doing philosophy
besides analytic and continental
classical american comes to mind one of
the the problems
with the dominance of analytic
philosophy
in america is that from about the 1950s
onward
the classical american philosophical
tradition which does include american
pragmatists like dewey
james purse you know royce arguably
but also goes way back to the american
transcendentalists
includes other people along the way
includes jonathan edwards includes the
american renaissance
writers all of that just got totally
pushed to the side and all of that has a
lot of similarities to philosophy
as a way of life we could also think
about the history of philosophy now
history of philosophy can be done
in a equally arid and boring way
as it is done by some people but it also
very often is done by philosophers
who want to study aristotle not just to
trace out his influences not just to
determine exactly what's being said in
this text but because they think
aristotle
has something to say to us or the stoics
have something to say to us
in the present and we might we might
think of other things mcintyre and
tradition constituted
rationalities as being very similar to
this this
project we could go on and on and on so
there's probably other
third ways to analytic and continental
philosophy
that that bear similarities to uh
philosophy is a way of life
so you know sellers is is not all that
convinced about this third way business
um i think that he's probably right in
in talking about this cutting across the
divides in part because we can find
people doing things like philosophy as a
way of life not only in the continental
traditions but also in at least early
analytic philosophy and perhaps even in
some contemporary
analytic philosophy as well so that's a
way to understand the
relation between philosophy as a way of
life
and these two predominant other
discourses or traditions
within the world of academic philosophy
you